gave me too much plum the end of the
quarter game
[Music]
he did it again
you like that Chicago now especially
that especial dangling because as he
checks o'clock and he comes up the floor
Rose is right there just goes right to
get off to the chaplain Brian will fire
sick three-point [ __ ] to finish the
hammer you kidding me
they'll change the down backs of LeBron
teased it deep three
[Applause]
final seconds first half my fatigue can
stop the other three quarters
[Applause]
Ron James electrifies and proud
and he's got 20 points at halftime names
percolating
now as he was aware
buzzer
[Applause]
Wake County
[Applause]
and LBJ is opening up the Arsenal for to
shoot James will he man it was a jump
shot from about 35 feet down with his
third rebound LA heat up scored 30
points or more in 34 in this quarter
LeBron banking in a three and me back he
did not do that but without a deflection
106 98 Washington James
sixteen seconds to play aims knocks down
his fourth three-pointer of the night
LeBron James have made a couple of these
tonight just coming down in transition
and poor not
[Music]
[Applause]
it's impossible
[Applause]
signs of when the captain's five and
seven I'm seeing in this game tonight
not a good time Ron takes a longer like
the lamb are you serious
that was a 28 footer LeBron says okay we
fall in love the jump shot I just had my
little continue now he's not gonna cats
just doing a nice job of keeping the
pace LeBron from way out
wow that's some range from LeBron James
and he wanted that son he came over to
Jordan Clark says hey give me the ball
knocked it in go ahead and last and pull
the trigger they're double-teaming the
pick-and-roll long range three by LeBron
gets it and a smile on his face looking
at the Pacer fans it is a six-point game
now
[Applause]
30 feet deep or way back at the - 89 78
Cavaliers five six of the last eight of
series full release Mozgov battling with
Martin Dean they swing it out to James
five on the shot clock
fires away a deep frame over Tucker what
[Music]
that's where you want to be an angle so
you can piss off the window
great patience
a game-high 34 for yo [ __ ] LeBron James
the pick and roll defense in TV
it is searching out the whole time ain´t
group behind the plate of the board can
it be tapped out nice to keep it alive
that's LeBron with a d3 its G pinch down
that's his first triple of the
knighthood
James just seventh 40-point game of
these playoffs steps tries it again puts
an end as the shot clock expires LeBron
James with 44 timeout Boston
back-to-back daga threes by LeBron James
the best player in the land don't do
that the current player not the Hall of
Famers Dellavedova out to Shepherd
jumpers that as I curry find the chute
snack out spread James puts up the grain
gets it to go
but Ron James from way downtown and the
Cavs go up by one he's got 10 points
here in the fourth quarter 34 for the
game James to love back up top
James a long pray
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
Sunday now as opposed to Saturday night
we just need to tell the rest of the
league to get the memo
to Santa Claus oh I hope curry takes
that person though it takes a step back
they says wait a minute that's my range
at least Copland cavaliers at 40 and 29
coming in LeBron James team hasn't lost
this many games in the regular season
since near his rookie year
Barbarossa mark another possession James
launches
[Applause]
he's really upset that he didn't get the
South Pole but the fact that he read the
plot was great McKee with the board two
seconds to go James a puzzler
[Applause]
as if there was ever a doubt he says
yeah
and nails at LeBron James closes out the
first half down by three they could tie
the game with seven his sexy years
Leblanc
LeBron to the time
[Applause]
this crowd is
this crowd is up the grandees calm they
got the ball and took a couple of casual
dribbles let fly and the results you're
hearing it from the fans you know down
by five where six actually went Guzman
found himself three in the corner and
LeBron making his way to the paint than
finding the hot hand for the Lakers and
that's Kuzma he knocks down his 37th
point of the offense only reason why
he's out there he is
fight fire went up shot from half court
[Applause]
and his 12 to a 50-point game for LeBron
Joe he deliberately shot that four men
those half courts told you didn't get
detected across midcourt there'll be a
turnover and the Bronx did it girl
LeBron with five with four shot clock is
on James pull off for a three that's the
way down deep and down deep very deep I
mean I knew he was setting him up for
the step-back but he was already at a
position where it would well behind the
line and Michael good luck because
tomorrow your Northwestern Wildcats took
on the Ohio State Buckeyes
down say goodnight
Lakers are on their way to a win over
the Mavericks almost lost it 10 on the
clock for James a deep three
[Applause]
hotter than fish grease right now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
spinning other needs that follow ads the
defense by karl-anthony towns and
company that's a throw out control right
to LeBron when you look at this they had
a fresh 24 and he hit a 30 footer
[Applause]
LeBron LeBron they had a new shot clock
in the brothers particle down what power
what power he possesses
those players have been accepted against
of at least twenty-five to fifty seven
percent with the Lakers right back to
answer LeBron shoots away and it's Davis
who pulls down the rebound out duals
LeBron for that board and how about
James vessel for LeBron James
they're looking at the spot on the floor
where he shot at a 40-footer plus for
LeBron James
he's done this the last couple acres at
one point led by for LeBron from way
down town that was concur evil who's my
operating on the perimeter
LeBron g-town Turner oh for LBJ yes sir